now on this international women's day
two important things to remember to
support women-owned businesses and of
course prioritize self-care
that's right well rocky theis has more
from a local shop where i understand you
can do both
welcome to sweet bubble bath confections
it's what i like to call
a bubble bath bakery because when you
walk in
you see all of these desserts and you
actually look like you're in a bakery
but you're not you're not making cookies
you're making soap we're making so
so tell us a little bit about this local
shop and first of all i just love
that it's family and woman owned it is
family owned we've been around in this
location for about 10 years
from our grandmother to my mom my
sisters
my dad actually helps out as well here
in the shop men deserve self-care too
everybody so what do you guys offer
so we offer pretty much everything
from old-fashioned soaps to bath bombs
to sugar scrubs
to our confetti cakes that we have up
here
yes so bath bombs and sugar scrubs but
all with a very
delectable delicious twist i might add
so let's talk about
this product right here because it looks
like cake but please i repeat do not eat
it
do not bite the bubble bath cake so
those are our confetti cakes
and also um bubble bath bars bowl bath
in the bar
form look at that you can break it apart
and throw it in your bath under
running water so what do you do you go
full i go full board let's do an entire
bar
we've created some bubble baths for you
all right it's like a little science
project
wow okay so what happens when you put it
in what goes on so
when you put it in it will actually
soften up i like to use it under running
water
you get a lot of bubbles um it's like a
cleansing bar
look at that very soft and soothing wow
and it smells good too
oh yes oh my goodness okay so yeah okay
got a little messy no worries we
that's what happens when you're in a
bake shop okay all right so
so this is it's not moisturizing it's
just for decoration
and gentle cleansing right gentle
cleansing okay okay so now let's move on
to
moisture because that's a very important
factor in self-care yes
absolutely and your bath bombs help with
that our bath bombs definitely do
this is a bath bomb very popular right
now but i've never really understood
what they do so let's talk about it
so they soften moisturize the skin um
once you put them in the water you can
kind of see what they're doing they're
a lot of bubbles compared to our bubble
bar over here
it has the shea butters and cocoa
butters really really good on your skin
to moisturize and soften
love to use them at the end of the day
taking a bath yes um with
with our bath bombs here and i want to
add you know
taking a bath is definitely a luxury and
something we should do
but also shower is very important too so
coming up later in the show
we're going to show you how to enhance
your shower experience
right we'll be back